>>Narrator: Thanks to gaming
and affordable housing,
Las Vegas is still booming.
But good news in the
job market is bad news
for the district's
high-school dropout rate,
one of the highest in the country.
>>Carlos: Las Vegas is different
than anywhere I've ever been,
because think about it, if you drop
out of school here, people have jobs.
And just think, you
can earn between 40
to 80 thousand dollars
parking cars here.
>>Okay, have a good night.
>>Carlos: So, you know, it's
a very unique situation.
>>Narrator: To combat the
high-school dropout problem,
the district has organized
an extensive network
of community volunteers.
>>Man: What are they doing?
>>They're camping.
>>Man: They're camping.
>>Carlos: Everybody thinks
that we're just this Disneyland
that people come to and leave.
No, we have over one-and-a-half
million people in the Valley here.
The community really is
involved in the schools.
The top CEOs come in and read to kids
in our school district, mentor kids,
and be good role models
so that our kids feel
that they're valued in our community.
>>Now, who helps you with
your homework at home?
>>My calculator.
>>Your calculator.
But does Mother help you?
>>Thomas: The more smart kids we
have, the better our future will be.
The more kids that are able to
take care of themselves and provide
for themselves, the
better we're going to be.
So I said, "Anyone who does not
have a kid in the school, share.
Just share what you have."
>>Narrator: While most
dropouts occur in high school,
the trouble usually begins in middle
school, so the district's Stay
in School Mentoring Project targets
seventh-graders, like Chaniece.
>>Chaniece: We just talk about
grades and stuff like that,
how I'm feeling some days,
and what I've been doing
over the weekends and
stuff like that.
>>Woman: So what else are you guys
going to do after the concert?
>>Narrator: Volunteers like Mary
Mitchell are trained by the district
and committed to visiting their
mentees at school once a week.
>>Mary: They may not
even have a problem.
They just need someone to just
listen to them talk, you know,
and actually hearing
what they're saying.
>>Michael: What we tell the mentors
is to do something with the student
that you both enjoy doing, something
that will facilitate conversation
so that the mentor would
have the opportunity
to get a little better understanding
of what might be going
wrong with that child.
>>Chaniece: A or B?
>>Mary: Let's go with A.
>>Chaniece: Okay.
>>Mary: I got involved because
I love kids, having children
of my own, and it's just a joy.
I do it for the pleasure of it.
She loves music, and I think
she's going to go far with it,
but she says she wants
to be an attorney.
And I think whatever Chaniece sets
her mind to do, I think she'll do it,
you know, because she's
very determined.
>>Chaniece: On the instrument,
this is what you call a scroll.
>>Man: If I asked you, "What is
13 times 5," can you tell me?
>>Carlos: The good news is the
other day the headline said
that we've decreased our dropout
rate, and we're really excited
about the fact that the community
has rallied to say, "You know,
the most important
thing are our children."
>>Man: 10 plus one more.
>>Boy: Is 11.
>>Man: Exactly.
So we're going to write 11 down.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to Edutopia.org.